the current with us you just drew a game
with Marcus Carlson I heard you just say
it was a boring game so uh could you
just tell us a bit more about it why do
you think it was boring well the opening
was boring okay they were trying super
hard
um and as Magnus that he's right it's a
very long tournament and any any break
you can get is useful I mean
were you happy you're playing with white
pieces episode of our advantage for you
so um we're satisfied I mean it doesn't
matter the main thing is I was down 30
seconds in the opening and in this time
control three plus two if you got way
down on time you don't have obvious
moves you just lose the game I mean it's
a game against you Yankee previous round
and normal situation probably five
second Ten Second increment he draws the
game easily with two seconds he just
falls apart so I was just down on time
and just made a practical decision and
that's life overall how you satisfy with
your performance so far in the blitz
yeah I mean my performance is pretty
good considering I mean uh conditions
yeah
so you're much more happier than
considering what happened in the Rapids
for you so um
now I'm about the rest of the day do you
feel rested or do you feel a bit tired
now because I mean I mean I feel okay
but it's 9 000 degrees in the playing
Hall and I mean it's affecting everybody
so yeah it's not great but that's what
it is the beginning of this blue summer
we had this issue about the dress code
what is your general opinion about that
I'll talk about that on my stream uh
after the event is over sure